it took me a long time to understand
that i had limiting beliefs especially
when i was doing well so when i started
making 80 and 90 000 a year in sales
this is many many years ago that's like
270 000
today in an industry by the way where
the top producers were forty thousand
the limiting beliefs that i had at that
time and then even when i was making a
million dollars a year were the ones
when i was making money you know when
you're not making any money it's clear
you got a limiting belief you know
you're making 30 grand a year and that's
all you can make no matter how good you
are no matter how much you smile no
matter how much service you provide no
matter how early you get there how late
you stay and you still make 30. you know
there's a limiting belief because
everything would indicate you should be
paid more when you're making a million
dollars a year you start thinking i
don't have any limiting beliefs so the
way to handle that is you need to study
people that have created massive amounts
this is exactly what the 10x rule was
about create massive amounts in the
millionaire booklet it talks about
earning money keeping money and
multiplying money this is what the great
sales people don't do i know great sales
people that have never figured out how
to multiply money i know sales people
that are so good like i'm like dude that
guy is probably a better sales person
than me but he's still broke he's broke
because he made his money didn't know
how to keep it
or he kept it didn't know how to
multiply it how much you earn is a
limited belief how you keep it where you
keep it is the limiting belief if you
have money in the bank or equity in your
house or you have a retirement account
you have a limiting belief about money
you're saving for a rainy day you have
equity in your home waiting to pay it
off in 30 years completely ridiculous no
no high performance person needs to
worry about paying their house off you
should rent where you live own
stuff that other people pay you for okay
and just rent where you live and be
mobile and the third thing is you know
planning for having cash sit in an
account just sitting dead in an account
or in your wall or underneath your bed
or in your safe or the vault wherever it
is but what about an emergency if your
money's in the bank and the internet
goes down you won't be getting your
money out there's no getting the money
if you got it underneath your bed what
what what for like some of you are
storing money in gold gold is a limiting
money belief you're like oh my god the
world's going to come to an end gold
will not help you out of the end of the
world scenarios you should make a whole
list of all the limiting beliefs that
you have around money number one number
two you should most importantly make a
list of limiting actions
not limiting beliefs because your
beliefs are turning into actions how you
save money how you spend money how you
invest money diversification is also a
limiting belief okay now i know a lot of
people recommend diversification
especially the people on wall street
that benefit from you diversifying the
most
they don't want you all eggs in one
basket but if you study the super
wealthy they took stakes once they got
super rich then they're like okay i'll
own the railroads the banks
and all the grocery stores
want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn these seven
rich people habits that you need to try
enjoy
habit number two is celebrate failure
with chamath pala hapatia so when i meet
an entrepreneur and they failed
the thing that i'm trying to figure out
is like how did they feel
is it again and this is going back to
what we talked about earlier did you
just not listen and keep battering your
head because you heard something or read
something and you just you know didn't
refuse to pivot that kind of
stubbornness can be good but it can also
be extremely destructive
you know did you fail because you got
the market wrong but you built a great
product
that's actually not such a bad thing
that happens right happens to the best
of us i mean i failed more times than
and then the last thing is you know are
you comfortable with that failure so the
people that can own it in my opinion um
that's a very special class of person
and
and part of it is just being around
enough people that's why silicon valley
is so great because it celebrates
failure as much as it celebrates success
and i think that's awesome like i grew
up in canada i love canada but what's
frustrating about being canadian is we
don't celebrate failure right and so
it's all about mean reversion it's all
about managing the middle and so if
you're an outlier you feel extremely
isolated
and you feel stupid when things don't go
right
as opposed to trying to learn from it
rinse and repeat try again right
so i'm trying to figure out you know
how did they fail
and what did they learn in general i
think it's a good thing
in general though what i would say
more importantly than anything else is
are you humble enough to realize
that
when things worked
it was you but it was also a lot of luck
and then are you courageous enough to
realize that when it failed it may not
have been as much you but you've learned
enough to now avoid the same mistakes
those are the two things that you have
to figure out you know you have to be
humble enough to realize like timing is
everything people are everything right
the team the conditions your competitors
so many things came into making
something work right at that time it's
not so replicable same similarly failing
if you failed for the right reasons
that could be great dna to go again and
try again habit number three take on the
world with stephen bartlett the things
that invalidated you when you're younger
will be the things you seek validation
from when you're older and for me
not being able to have
people at my house not being able to
celebrate birthdays and christmases
these they carved this insecurity into
me that as i get to 16 17 18 years old i
just want to fill and as you say like a
lot of successful people if you dig into
their stories you'll find this moment
this trauma this event that happened in
their early years and of course it's
then the thing that often makes them
successful
but
the reason they become successful is
because they're in some way unusual
right they might be obsessive about
money or power or control and that often
also comes with a unappreciated downside
which means they might find it really
hard to form relationships which i did
and they might be a little bit too
selfish they might be you know they
might chase after material things
thinking it's happiness get there it
moves away like a mirage and they're
left with a lack of fulfillment um to
answer your question about what the
things were in me that made me move
differently one of them was by the age
of 10 years old my parents were never in
the house and when i said oh never i
mean like i would wake up they weren't
there and when i went to bed they
weren't there so at 10 years old i have
to fend for myself and you think think
about the pressures going on in my life
at that age i'm a kid who is feeling
like really inadequate and insecure
because i have nothing and my parents
aren't there so i'm looking around
thinking how can i fill this void so i'm
thinking i'm going to do a deal with the
local vending machine company to stock
our school with vending machines and
we're going to get 20 of the revenue and
i'm going to take a little bit of a cut
and i'm going to organize all of the
events in my school and this was my way
of like i had independence and i had an
insecurity and when the two came
together i became this young kid who
just had no choice but to take on the
world um on his own
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there how about number four know your
numbers with tillman fertitta this is
the problem with college and is that
they teach you the theoretical side of
everything for the person that's working
for you but it doesn't teach you to be
the ceo the practical side and the young
entrepreneur whether you're trying to go
up the corporate ladder or you are doing
it you're on and it's just the simple
things of and these are some of my great
tillmanisms from the book and why
harpercollins came to me and asked me to
write this book was
know your numbers okay you've got to
know your numbers there are no spare
customers we're all in a consumer
business
people watching this podcast for you or
me serving casino customers restaurant
customers hotel customers there are no
spare customers we're all after the same
consumer to the 95 5 rule that 95 of
everything is right so look for the five
percent that's wrong how about number
five choose who you associate with with
ed mylett the most powerful way
and the easiest way to change your
thermostat setting is by adding people
to your circle
very close proximity that live at a
higher temperature in that area than you
do for example in your faith let's just
say you're a 75 degree or in your faith
you've already seen this you can't
possibly begin to regularly associate
with good godly people who pray
regularly who try to live righteously
and there are 110 120 degrees of of
faith in their life and not have that
proximity heat you up now you won't get
to where they are you'll get to
somewhere between where you are at 75
degrees and they are at 110 over time
you become a hundred degree and you
alter the thermostat setting through
association same in business if you and
i were to hang around each other every
single day and let's say you were a 75
degree or in business hypothetically and
i don't know that about you but let's
just say you were
and i was 150 degree and we hung around
each other all the time don't you think
through that association especially if
you had two or three or four people like
me in your life that just over time you
don't even feel it you're at 80 you're
85 you're at 90 you're at 95. and that's
where you are we understand the power of
this with our children
because we know at school the teachers
have influence over them they're mentors
but the people that really have
influence over our children are for
their friends because they're around
them all the time and so we know it sets
their temperature this is true in
fitness if you're a 75 degree of fitness
at every meal every day at the gym all
your associations hypothetically
speaking we're with someone who was
shredded and fit the way you wanted to
look at 150 degrees you know over time
you get heated up and so you can't be
with someone every day you can't be with
them all the time but the key is to get
more proximity in the areas that matter
with people whose thermostat setting is
higher than yours i am a product you are
listening to me right now because i've
been so obsessed with this concept of
adding new associations to my life that
live in the areas that i want to improve
in at higher temperatures than me it's
my obsession to this day i'll give you a
secret one of the reasons i even do my
show is i know that i'm influencing many
of these guests in the areas that matter
most to them through our proximity and
in some cases they do it for me and so
i'm obsessed with the power of
association but i don't just associate
see
all personnel says yeah you're the five
people you hang around
kinda
you really are the five to ten people
you hang around if you're conscious all
the time
of studying them of observing them of
asking questions of the fact that you
should be altering your thermostat
setting that's when it really moves it's
not just hanging around it's consciously
and intentionally spending time with
people
where you allow it to impact you where
you study them where you really observe
them where you're open to their
influence there has to be a level of
trust before you can do that where you
surrender yourself to them but it's not
just being around them it's
intentionally being around people that
alters that thermostat setting so power
of association is the main way to do it
habit number six feed your mind with
positivity with tony robbins
fundamentally the most basic thing you
gotta do especially a time like covet is
you gotta every day have a couple of
simple practices one of those is every
day you got to feed your mind and when i
say fiji miami consciously seek out
something that's going to give you new
insight new inspiration new way of
looking things because otherwise today
the news follows you right it's in your
pocket in the news people are good
people but they're doing their job
what's their job make as much profit as
possible how do you get the most profit
get the most people to watch i get the
most people to watch fear
if it you know
if it bleeds it leads is the phrase they
use in journalism right and we've seen
so much fear built up now that most
people have lost their faith and you
can't lose it fortunately it's just a
muscle that needs to be regained but you
have to fill your mind you have to
pursue it great ideas are not going to
interrupt you they have to be pursued
and the good news is today if you get
away from just the traditional news you
can do a lot of podcasts like boss vapes
you can go to different locations you
can get another perspective and you can
feed your mind but if you don't feed
your mind my original teacher was a guy
named jim rum
and he used to say tony i got a question
for you
he said what if
your worst enemy puts sugar in your
coffee what's going to happen to you
when you drink that coffee so you're
going to have sweet coffee he said you
know what if your family member your
friend your love by accident drops one
drop of strychnine what's going to
happen when you drink that coffee is
that you're going to be dead he goes
that's right
life is sugar and strychnine so watch
your coffee like every day you've got to
stand guard at the door of your mind
especially at times like this when
there's so much fear and habit number
seven the last one before some very
special bonus clips is love your work
with tom bilyeu my average week is
probably 90 hours 85 to 90 hours my
average i routinely pop over 100 if
something really has to get done
the key is to
structure your life in such a way that
the work is
joyful
so
the reason that i so when my wife and i
exited our last company we never needed
to work again ever
i mean just never had to think about
money again and
we thought okay what we want to do
though is
really do something gives us meaning and
significance so let's build something
for if we're going to work when we don't
have to let's make sure that what we
build is something that that fills us in
ways that we can't explain
and for me storytelling has always been
just a calling i love it so much and i
cannot tell you how much i love writing
so
jeff bezos very aptly said that in any
job no matter how much you love it
there's a certain amount of overhead
things you don't like doing so monday
through friday i'm doing my overhead
when i work on the weekends
with precious few exceptions it's never
overhead it's writing it's editing a
story it's looking at concept art it's
you know doing things that have to be
done for the business but also in and of
themselves i find so
energizing and exciting
that
it's
arguably the best way that i could spend
that's why it i do it during my selfish
time so my wife and i take selfish time
she draws she's a world-class artist
absolutely breathtaking and i will write
or do something around the stories and
that to me is is incredible so it's a
lot of hours for work but like they say
if you love what you do you'll never
work a day in your life so that's how
i'm able to hit the kind of crazy
numbers that i hit or the number of
books that i read it's like i love that
it lights me on fire i'm excited to do
it i'm not trudging through it
entrepreneurship is one of the hardest
things that you're ever going to do in
your life
and it's totally worth it
it's totally worth it whether it
actually works out or not most
entrepreneurs will fail something like
85 percent of businesses fail in the
first five years most businesses won't
work but it's totally worth it why
because
you're showing yourself that you bet on
yourself you're showing yourself that
you're following through and taking
action on your ideas that you're worthy
you're showing yourself that you're
worthy
you're showing yourself that you believe
in you
and if you keep doing that
you're gonna win
the path to living a happy life a
fulfilled life a life that you're proud
of
is one where you continue to show up for
yourself
and the minute that you stop when you
stop showing up for yourself when you
just throw in the towel and say this is
over i'm just gonna work for somebody
else i'm going to help somebody else
build their dreams instead of chasing
down mine
that's when life starts to fall apart
you know that's the path down
to unhappiness and depression and it
doesn't mean that everybody has to be an
entrepreneur
but what you have to do is continue to
bet on yourself you have to continue to
bet on your ideas you have to continue
to say i came up with this good idea
and because i came up with it therefore
it's a worthy endeavor for me to chase
it down
i got asked on my live stream yesterday
how do i know when to quit you know is
quitting is quitting bad
do i quit on something how do i know
when to quit
some people say never give up never give
up always keep going and some people
are the opposites what's the right
advice
the right answer is if you love it you
have to keep going
if you love it you have you have to find
a way to keep going
so for a lot of cases
that's what entrepreneurship is you've
got a dream you've got a mission you've
got some goals that that you genuinely
love that you really want to to build to
create to serve to help people with
and it's that love that's going to keep
you going
because in the early days it's going to
suck it's the it's the
chewing glass and eating to the abyss
right you have that moment of high at
the beginning of i'm going to start this
thing oh my god it's so exciting and
then you you land into the valley of no
momentum nothing working not no results
nobody praising you anymore nobody's
celebrating you for starting the
business
now you're in the actual running of it
and you're not getting the results that
you want and you're trying to show how
you're winning and post it on instagram
and you're but you're not and you know
you're not and you feel like a fraud
and this is this is the life cycle that
a lot of entrepreneurs go through but if
you love it
you have to keep going you have to you
have to you have to
you could be a lot more honest you could
be a lot more vulnerable you could be a
lot more authentic
you can understand that you have you
don't have to do this all by yourself
this is my biggest problem when i
started my company i was i was failing i
was flat out failing i was 300 bucks a
month like
failing
and i was too embarrassed and ashamed to
tell my friends that i was feeling i
wanted to look like
i was doing well because i turned down
the jobs that they all went and got and
they're all making
high five figure low six figure jobs at
a university and i'm
making
300 bucks a month i was just embarrassed
i was just too embarrassed and i made it
harder on myself
to be alone
you don't have to be alone you can make
it easier by just letting people in
when you're down in the dumps being by
yourself is usually the worst thing
if you can be around other people
especially people who support you
a lot of people will
let's circle back to
the idea that if you don't love it
you're going to regret it why why do you
have to keep going
why do you have to keep going why is it
so important if you love it because you
will regret it
because you will look back on this
moment in your life and say i should
have
done more i could have done more i
regret not giving it one more week one
more month
one more year i regret it you will
regret it that's the only thing that
saved my first business
i quit on my partner i told him i'm done
i need to feel like i'm a valuable human
again nothing i'm doing is working and i
hate how this makes me feel as a person
nothing against
you or the business just how i feel i
need to feel like i'm valuable again
somehow
that was the conversation and then the
next day woke up and i said i can't quit
because i'm gonna regret this i know i'm
gonna regret this i'm gonna be
an old man at 40.
i'm 41 now i'm getting an old man at 40
and regret that i wasted my life and i
didn't do this thing
and that's the only thing that gave me
the the courage
the motivation the energy to get back up
and just keep going you will regret this
if you love it and you stop now you will
regret this for your entire life
now on the flip side
i think there are many things that you
should quit on sooner
the the difference is if you don't love
it you need to quit on it if you don't
love it anymore and maybe you never
loved it in the first place then you
need to move on because you will never
win doing work that you hate
the people who are at the top of their
game people have i've studied how many
successful people have i studied and
profiled and showcased on on all of
these channels how many so many people
right
the one thing they all have in common is
that they love what they do they love
the process they love the work they love
the grind it's not a grind for them
because they're in it so much and they
love it
so that's who you're going up against
right and if you don't love it you're
always going to lose no matter how smart
you are you're going to lose because
you're going up against people who
absolutely love the thing
and so that's what you need you need to
be loving your thing and so if you're in
it just as a strategy
you're going to lose move on immediately
as soon as your heart's not into it
either sell it or if it's too new then
then you just flat out move on i think
people saying relationships are too long
i think people stay in businesses for
too long because you're afraid of
failure because you're afraid of what it
means if you quit on something and go to
something else you're afraid of what
people are gonna say you're afraid of
what the person looking back at you in
the mirror is gonna think if you quit
you're afraid of the uncertainty of
where to go next because if this thing
at least i know what this thing is doing
i don't know what the future holds to me
if i go somewhere else
a lot of people are handcuffed by having
a little bit of money not not a lot but
enough to survive
and that then prevents them from taking
the next jump which they actually need
to do because their heart's not in the
thing
so many people start a business because
they're just trying to make money
people ask me what's what's the number
one
business to get into for this year to
make a lot of money that's the wrong
question you're asking that question
you're gonna lose you can't start with
how to make money you start with the
thing that you love that brings value
and inside of that you're making money
making money is important a hundred
percent if you don't make money you will
not have a business making money has to
be in your top five of priorities but if
you make it number one you're gonna lose
because you're always gonna be chased in
the next hot thing
never get good enough at anything to
actually be the best in the world which
is actually how you start to make a lot
of money you need to be the best in the
world at something how do you get that
by loving the things so much
and by wanting to serve and help people
get better at it too
that's how you win you know i find if
i'm stressed about something it's
usually because i'm not doing anything
about it and so if i'm stressed about
something i'm trying to figure out why
am i stressed i'm listening to my body
as a signal
that i'm that something is awry and then
i find that the stress goes away
the second i take the first step of you
know identify the source of the stress
why am i stressed about this what's
going on
and then
you know talk to somebody about it find
you know find allies
um you know i would say that
if you can find
friends
who are interested in similar things or
want to help you solve a problem
problem solving is
is
inspiring for me all by itself i have
as long as i have allies there's nothing
more fun than getting in a room
with a group of
uh inventors and saying look
here's the problem let's invent a
solution to it and as soon as you start
doing that i find that it turns from
something that might create stress
into something that
creates fun you know if if you
see self-improvements not even just with
cars with your own body you know when
you go work out
do you feel better when you come out of
gym all pumped up or you feel better
when you haven't worked out for a month
of course you know you're when you go to
the gym you know you're building your
you know something happens when you see
changes in your body with your assets
when you see even
gaining a good friend i have my down
days you know i'm sure you do too we're
all human you know you could have all
the money in the world you're still
going to have a bad day you know
absolutely you don't know what's going
to cause it but you know you do and you
know for me working out is great i have
a personal trainer three times a week
and then when i don't have my personal
trainer i just get out of bed and drop
on the floor and do 20 push-ups 30
push-ups i do it until i can't do it
anymore and then i hit the shower and i
feel great you know yeah and it's you
know it's just
keeping the fluids going you know your
mind fresh yeah because workout not just
improves your physics it also helps your
mind a greed and uh sometimes it helps
your mentality more than your physique
but people don't realize it you know it
helps you focus you know now i'm going
through and teaching myself neural
networks and you know doing the same
thing with machine learning and gans and
this and that because
ai is going to have more of an impact
than the internet did ai plus new types
of chipsets plus 5g is going to change
things far more than we've ever seen
anything change and understanding where
and how to apply it is going to be
critical but just as important knowing
how to sub
um segregated and separate
yeah right is as important because every
email you are about to send me
is going to say i have this ai solution
and we're using algorithms
yeah of course you are right and then
what what really makes you different
what really sets you apart but if i
didn't do that work if i didn't sit down
and do the aws machine learning
tutorials if i didn't go on youtube and
take you know the nyu introduction to
neural networks or whatever i'm not
going to know it i'm not going to be
able to apply it and i'm not going to be
able to be first and that's fun that's
fun knowing i get to kick the ass to
some 22 year old nyu graduate that's
awesome you know
do it anyway
is a mindset trick that you can use when
you start to feel excuses rolling up it
works a lot like the five-second rule so
you
have said to yourself okay i'm gonna
talk to my boss today
about that thing that i've been avoiding
talking to them about or maybe you've
said something like i'm gonna go to the
gym today or tomorrow or whatever and
then the moment comes where you've gotta
have that conversation
or the moment comes where it's time to
pack up your bag and leave your desk and
go to the gym
and what always happens
you don't feel like it
i bet there are plenty of you watching
that have made a commitment that i'm not
going to have a drink tonight and then
guess what happens when you get home
you don't feel like not drinking you
feel like having a drink and so here's
what do it anyway has done for me
the idea that i just do it anyway
has pushed me to realize and to
recognize that there are a lot of
moments where there are things in my
life that i really
want to do
i need to do
i should do
but when the moment comes
i don't feel like it
and so i pull out this idea of you know
what i'm just gonna do it anyway
it's raining outside i said i would go
for a short run i don't feel like it i'm
gonna do it anyway it's six o'clock in
the morning i'm tired
it's cold
i laid out my yoga clothes but now i
don't feel like it what do i do i do it
anyway when you start to say to yourself
i'm gonna do it anyway what happens is
something really cool
you acknowledge
that there are feelings that you have
that are trying to swoop in and hijack
you
you acknowledge them and you basically
say guess what
i'm going to do it anyway how do you get
to where you're at how do you think the
way you think how can you
self-actualize how can you be positive
do you have
can you identify a reason well for me
it's a little easier than maybe for some
people because one when you're down and
out more than once you don't know money
no nothing and something good happens oh
boy this is great but i was with all due
respect i was born i think positive
i i my mom would always tell me my god
be careful mom i'm gonna be just fine i
was kind of think boring positive
you know then obviously when you're down
you go up you get even more positive
because you're so happy and then when
you have an abundance of something and
you get to share it with people and you
see a good end result it just it's happy
if you ever you do something for
somebody else and ask absolutely nothing
in return it's the greatest high you'll
ever get now i went through the 60s okay
it's the greatest high you'll ever get
when you help somebody say that and you
ask nothing in return yes absolutely
nothing in return it's higher than
smoking anything is that what how you
would describe a good giver
yeah when you give to somebody or
something or some environment whether
it's the environment for the planet or
for people
and you ask nothing in return you do it
because it's the thing to do
oh you get a good high everyone likes
being knowledge but do it sometime and
don't tell anybody you did it like
there'll be times austin especially i'll
go downtown and when i'm in l.a i'll do
it because i was homeless here once and
i'll hand out hundred dollar bills i'll
just go back to this freedom
and i just keep on walking and one lady
they gave a stack to it was a ten
thousand dollar stack she was just the
kind of sweetest lady and i talked to
her a little bit she told me a little
about her life and i said can i give you
a couple dollars oh no no i found out a
way to make it okay because i don't like
to ask for anything they said okay so i
just held her hand and i said can i put
a note in your pocket sure so i just put
a note in the pocket without realizing
spilled ten thousand output in her
pocket there was folded with a rubber
band i said you are so blessed
won't you wait a few minutes before
reading my note say a little prayer then
read that out okay and i disappeared i
write down my day
and what i do is i go back and study
that day like sometimes i might i might
get sick i might be over trained i might
um
gain a couple pounds here i might feel
whatever
that and i it's like my accountability
journal
of what i'm doing with my life physical
mental um
i had an eating journal all that
and helps me go back to once again study
i'm a lab rat
and i study myself
and i'm like when i'm feeling [ __ ] up
i go okay what i do last week
and usually i can find out where i
messed up
last week you know how much i'm
traveling how much i'm sleeping how much
i'm doing all this stuff and
and through journaling man you can
really figure out so much
about where you're messing up in life
and what you need to fix about yourself
taking constant inventory costing honest
about that and that's the thing about
you cannot put in there yeah it's got to
be a real a real journal about hey today
i messed up here today i should have
been a better person here and not just
saying it but actually trying to fix it
tomorrow what's the best advice that
you've received someone told me that
what you delegate is 80
as good as you would have done it
yourself let it go oh wow i took
inventory of what am i good at what am i
not good at what do i you know enjoy and
don't enjoy and they're usually the same
thing ironically like i was very clear
in the first year i was not good at
shipping and handling and i wasn't good
at you know
so many different things about managing
the inventory but i loved inventing the
next idea i loved the brand i loved the
way that i was communicating with
consumers so being able to free yourself
up to do what you do best and let the
people who do the other aspects to us do
it what problems out there can feasibly
be fixed say in our lifetimes
well i mean i think first of all
um
the world's actually pretty great right
now uh i mean arguably better than any
point in history um and this this is
sometimes uh lost if you read the
newspapers they're
they're like
a
magnification of all
the world's problems it's like
i mean newspapers seem to be attempting
to answer the question what was the
worst thing that happened on earth today
[Applause]
yeah it's
yeah if it bleeds elites yeah and and
it's like okay i mean and i think
there's
there is kind of a evolutionary reason
for that because it makes more sense to
like you want to
prioritize danger over reward or or
because
it's
if you get eaten by the lion game over
but
you know if if you forget where you left
some snack that's that's okay i mean
you know so
so there's a
it's it's
not quite the same in terms of the
restaurant balance but
we didn't evolve with newspapers uh and
and and global media so
like our brains sort of having a fear
response to a bunch of dangers that are
extremely unlikely to ever affect us i
turned it around you know i
i did my job
in four hours and i was on
there was a wall that separated
production from the offices and the
lunchrooms
because in production there was you know
quality control you couldn't go in there
unless you had hair nets and you know
protective equipment
so what i did is i borrowed some
protective equipment i went in there and
i started hanging out with the operators
the people that were running the lines
and i started taking their trash outside
uh and then uh
if they want this is cool this is the
truth i don't know you know people will
like it but if they wanted a cigarette
break
you know to go outside and smoke because
you know this is this is 70 right you
know everybody smokes uh so i would say
well just show me what to do you know
you just be gone for five minutes and
they're like uh i don't know like come
on just i'm i'm a mechanic you know i
really am
you know and so they would teach me you
know uh how to watch the line and they
would go outside
you know and i'd do that for a couple of
weeks and so so the other managers were
were telling my manager like hey uh
the guy on your crew that mops in the
night man hey uh i just want to thank
you for letting him take my trash out my
guys help him and they were like what
who did that
you know and he was like
like okay he was like no one had ever
done that
you know you heard the old statement
that's not my job
after he told after he told me that i i
never said i said i'm employed here that
is my job
you know that is my job and
and little by little i learned how to
run the the dorito lines you know how
them and it is it is like being a pilot
it's not you know people say you just
make chips oh no no man it's like you
got to go to pilot school to learn how
to make
doritos and potato chips and fritos
believe me it takes a couple years to be
a master what does max out really stand
for for you and when did that moment
happen where you knew that that was
gonna be part of your brand yeah um
my son's name's max so that helped um
but maxed out to me means this as you
know
your obsessions become your possessions
whatever you end up being obsessed with
you'll eventually possess so if you're
obsessed with what you're worried about
your fears your problems you're going to
possess those
and so
i became obsessed um the the short
version is is that you don't know this i
don't talk about this on camera very
much when i was 30 my uncle died at 50
years old
and he was the guy in my family we all
have this that you kind of resemble or
remind everybody else
my dad's brother he died at 50. sorry no
thank you i appreciate that it's a long
time ago now and um but he was kind of
was my godfather and all my culture
that's a big deal of course mine as well
yeah i know shout out uncle mike yeah
mine was uncle mike
whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa it's got chills
everywhere right there whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
whoa
whoa
man that's how the universe works right
wow okay
you got me right there
so mine was my uncle mike
wow
and
no man i just touched me
so
mine was my uncle mike and uh that blows
my mind right there brother
so
i'm on i'm at his funeral
we're flying back on the flight
there's this thing in your brain called
the reticular activating system it
basically filters into your awareness
what's important to you that's why like
if you buy a new car all of a sudden you
see that car everywhere on the freeway
three lanes over on the other side boom
another one they were always there why
do you see him now filtered into your
importance
and heart attacks were at my he died of
a heart attack and so i'm on the
airplane and i'm listening to music and
on the screens the oprah show but i'm
it's in my awareness and it's a heart on
the screen i'm like
unplugged my headphones plug it into the
phone system and it was about a new
heart scan that was happening at cedar
city where they could like it's common
now but they could not evasively look at
your heart and your arteries
long story short
i hear it and i told my wife i said
schedule me for one of those exams she's
like it's expensive i don't care
schedule it we call it's a nine month
wait i go i need to get in i need to get
in i keep calling the lady finally she
goes there's a cancellation tomorrow at
two i go i'll be there so i go down for
the scan and thank god this doctor
understood influence and leverage do you
do the scan then you come back after
lunch i literally went ate a burrito
came back i wasn't in shape i'm 30 years
old the doctor comes out and he goes um
i'm no i'm looking for edward milot i go
it's my let you know and he goes uh he
knew and he goes
whoa i can't believe these arteries are
in that younger body wow you need to
come back son
now my
heart's racing i'm like what the hell's
in the skin we sit down instead of what
a normal doctor would do they just go
hey um here's the prescription take
crest store workout eat goodbye
he understood reasons is what changes
people's lives massive reasons not
discipline reasons and habits right
because let me ask you a question your
wife's beautiful
um
do you have kids i go yeah i go i got a
son he's one he goes that's great um do
you want to be there when he graduates
high school
i went what he goes do you want to be
there when he graduates high school i
said uh yeah he goes
okay uh is she pregnant huh i go yeah
what is she having i said a girl you get
to a dad this is what you say he goes
would you like to walk that little girl
down the aisle on her wedding day son
i went what what is in this scan dude
and he goes i want to be very clear with
you young man i remember this like
yesterday because i want to be very
clear with you young man
if you continue down the road you're
going another man's going to live with
your beautiful wife in your mansion
walk your son at graduation and he's
going to be arm in arm with your
daughter on her wedding day not you
you'll be long gone actually as i tell
you this right now dude right
and he goes what i'm going to get you to
do is i'm going to get you to max out
your life and your fitness
and i went
give me it
yeah and he gave me exactly what i
needed to do and he said if you do this
you'll walk her down the aisle blah blah
blah from that day
when i get up like i did this morning
and i'm tired and i was late last night
and i don't want to go to the gym i
swear to you brother i swear to you i go
bella's wedding get your ass up and i go
i i'm fit because i have massive reasons
that's why i'm fit and that started the
journey towards maxing out every area of
my life i'm like i can do this in my
fitness i can do this in business i can
do this in my spirituality and
everything i'm not going to shortchange
myself by pretty good i'm gonna see what
my real potential is what my maximum
capacity is every single day because at
the end of my life when i do die i have
this belief that when i'm done the
lord's gonna go well done good and
faithful servant and by the way here's
the man you could have been
this is the man you were born to be this
is the man you were destined to be this
is where you could have gone but you
could have seen the memories you could
have had the people you could help the
person you could have become and meet
him my obsession is that every day i'm
chasing that dude so that when i do die
we meet with identical twins because the
bad end of a life whether it would be at
30 50 or 150 would be i meet that guy
and we're total strangers yeah so i'm
obsessed with meeting that guy someday
and that's what maxing out means i've
made myself you know understand
i.t information technology and if you
talk to any ceo of any company they'll
tell you that's the one department that
you do not want to
because no matter who you bring in
everybody has their own way of doing it
and and i've just still made myself uh
understand technology even though i'm
not a millennial i try to at least know
a little bit about every single
department even if i don't know it a lot
and so walk me through you want to learn
about i.t what do you do you googling it
or do you go sit down with the head of
i.t and say teach me everything no i
just i i want to i want to know
everything i want to understand this you
know you know malware how people are are
getting into all of our systems and
hackiness and
and uh i just process for learning
though just sitting down and say you got
to make me smarter on this you got to
you got to help me through these steps
because i don't get it don't go into too
much minutia because you'll lose me
because i'm not that smart but you got
to give me the steps of why this is
happening or not happening and that's
something that everybody should do you
don't have to understand you know that
i'm going to go and be able to program
something or or write something but but
we should all if we're running a company
understand some portion of it uh when
i'm shooting billion dollar buyer i know
what all these different people do and
exactly what they're doing and how
important you know each person is and
and uh it's just trying to understand
what you do and it makes you appreciate
that person and how smart they are at
that job too and how important they are
to your company i was a dnf student
i uh
i sucked at school
like i got like i actually was so bad at
school that i had my
my admin my my assistant reach out to my
high school and get a copy of my report
card so i could put on instagram the
other day because people are confused
what success looks like or how you get
there doesn't mean that you should look
at me and not do school it means that
you need to look at yourself and figure
out who you are
what are you good at what do you like
how are you going to get to the place
that you want to get to
and so for me
i got four a's in high school my entire
career all in gym
right like i got a d in yearbook
you know and so to me there's just a
thousand paths out there and so
for me i'm curious about one by one one
by one for the 30 people in this room
where's their mindset where are they at
who are they listening to
what are they judging their self-worth
and their ambition based on
how are they counting the points because
when you're a youngster
you're looking at all sorts of different
things you're being affected by all
sorts of different voices
and for me the only thing that worked
even though i was getting d's and f's
and all my friends parents told me i was
a loser even all my teachers told me i
wasn't going to be anything even though
i didn't have stuff even though i was
i just was in my own head i knew exactly
who i was but the thing that i was
willing to do was i was willing to work
and the thing that my parents taught me
was not to dwell
not to cry about it i didn't have [ __ ]
when i when i rolled up on my mom when i
was nine when nintendo
was popping because
when it first broke i was like mom i
need nintendo she's like good go get it
we're very interested in physical stores
and we haven't i've been asked for years
we ever opened physical stores literally
20 years have been asked the question
and i always say yes but only when we
have
a differentiated
differentiated offering something that's
not me too
because that space physical storage is
so well served if we offer a me to
product offering it's not going to work
and it's also just we're not very good
at that most of the whenever we've tried
dabbling in something that's a me too
service we tend to get
beaten it doesn't work we're
our culture is much better at pioneering
and inventing and so we have to have
something that's different and that's
what amazon go is it's completely
different the amazon bookstore
completely different and we have ideas
about how to merge prime and whole foods
to make that
those are still rolling out you haven't
seen them yet but to make to use amazon
prime to make whole foods a very
differentiated experience and so what
we're going to be able to do is take
some of our resources some of our
technical technological know-how and and
expand the whole foods mission
they have a great mission which is to
bring nourishing food to everybody
organic nourishing food to everybody
and
but you know we have a lot to bring to
that table in terms of resources but
also in terms of operational excellence
and in terms of technology know-how how
you talk to the existing consumers are
very different now you talk to the
future consumers all with the same brand
so whenever you have an immediate budget
now you have to divide up between
the old line traditional media and the
new
tools that are digital social media we
have to figure out a allocation
mechanism
with uncertain returns on investment in
the short term so this is a long term
brand building first point
second is
we have to figure out
how to advertise differently because you
just can't take a tv commercial that was
developed for
x factor and just plonk it on digital
media and say you know this is the new
way we're going to reach you you guys
will reject it so we have to talk to you
completely differently we almost have to
let you interact with the brand as
opposed to it being a one-way
conversation so what we're learning to
do is hire new people
allow them to experiment
allow them
to experiment in ways that says you
don't have to adhere to the old rules
that existed in pepsico which is all
difficult for us you know as i said when
you have boomers and gen xs running the
company and you allow
you actually think they're sort of
cowboys because they want to do things
that are so alien to what we were
brought up with at the same time we're
allowing a lot of the young people to
experiment i've noticed something in my
life the people that are really good
want to work with the best people they
can find
hopefully people that are even better
than them
you know i mean that's my view of things
is if
if you work with people that aren't as
good as you then you know you become a
country of midgets
if you work with people that are better
than you
then you really grow the only thing i
can control my life are the things that
i'm willing to take responsibility for
these gladiators that came here
thousands of years ago and maybe lost
their lives
if they took responsibility for the
match full responsibility and i might be
taking this too far right now i don't
know i don't know what it was like to be
a gladiator in 720 740 a.d okay i can't
even imagine fighting in front of 50 000
people with lions possibly coming out to
eat me okay but i know this you really
got to get this point carried away you
got to get it like in your head you're
an executive you're a business owner
you're a manager you're trying to hire
people you're trying to hire people and
you're like oh the people are bad
everybody's terrible everybody's bad i
can't find good people to take
responsibility we all have something to
do with what's going on around us
you and i authorize others to drop the
bomb look i've been robbed twice in my
life 23 years old i was almost killed
guy came in my house put a 45 caliber
pistol in my face hit me right here then
put 70 stitches in my head and face
robbed me
in new orleans louisiana i was robbed
at a younger age
i caused both of those i was the victim
in both situations
on the police report victim robbed by
criminals truth is i wasn't a victim i
created both of those wrong place wrong
time wrong people i had something to do
with that
everything that happens to you is
because of you
quit passing it off
right it's going to rain on me right now
while i'm shooting this
dude that's my fault i could have shot
this thing yesterday when it was
sunshine
watch and read high performance people
and you will see that they always take
responsibility when their life goes to
to garbage it's when they quit taking
responsibility the greats in the world
keep track of everything when they're in
the game
when they're the gladiator when they're
the ball player when they're the
executive of a big company they're
statizing everything okay how many
outbound how many inbound uh what's our
closing ratio what's our right ratio
everything is measured measure your
actions and measure your results those
that don't and won't are irresponsible
and they will cause you problems
i remember as a young salesperson i was
keeping a log not on what i sold but on
what i said to people i kept everything
how many people i talked to how many
people i waited on how many people i
wrote up how many people i negotiated
with how many people i closed how many
people i talked to on the phone and also
what they said and what i said what
worked and what didn't work i was taking
responsibility this is the only way you
can take responsibility by the way
you can't just say oh i'm responsible
you got to do something to follow up the
responsibility
it's how i handle
and learned and became a professional
salesperson i handle the future by
handling by being responsible for the
present
you go in that gladiator you go in there
as a gladiator in that coliseum okay and
you don't figure out how you lost that
last fight you're gonna die on the next
one take responsibility even if the
other guy cheated
he surprised you he shocked you he
pulled out some other weapon you didn't
know about be prepared for the future by
taking responsibility for the president
so be responsible be the cause not the
effect be responsible even when you're
not responsible be responsible bad
things happen to good people good things
by the way happen to good people and
blame no one be responsible and remember
this you want to be great you want to be
super successful take responsibility for
everything
even the things that you could have no
responsibility this is where trainers
mess people up
i've had trainers who totally just want
to prove that you could never
do what they do and then and they have
you paying i know what you mean just to
say like oh you're not as good as me and
they go to blast you like they want you
unless you're in pain and you feel like
you're sick and you're throwing up
you're like yeah that's a workout now
they look at you yeah you hurt you can't
walk great yeah and the whole point is
what i tell people is treat the gym like
a spa the first time you ever go just go
in there and walk around touch the
weights get a drink of water walk around
and then leave
and and i mean literally do that for
like a week two weeks until you just get
to the habit of getting in that door
because what's gonna happen is
eventually you're gonna start lifting
because you're there yeah and you're
going to do something and then you stop
don't ever get to the point where you're
like i can't feel my heart
it doesn't work i've been working people
want they say they want my body and all
this stuff but i've been working out
consistently since i was 14 years old
right and i'm 44. i've been 30 years
years of hardcore 2-hour workout 30
years yeah so it doesn't happen
overnight you just have to enjoy the
process totally learn to enjoy it
because i'm sure there was a point where
you started to enjoy losing 113 pounds
yep and that's the only way you're going
to keep going the tax department which
every country has taxes
determined they want to know what kind
of income do you work for
so when you say to someone your age or a
child to the parent parent to the child
they say is go to school get a job
they're working for this type of income
earned income
as you can see from this diagram here
as you can see from this diagram here
this is earned income here
and the first thing you pay is the
highest taxes because you worked for
money
yeah the government doesn't want you
working for money they punish you for
that they want you to hire employees
or invest
okay so earned income is what they work
for the second
is portfolio income it's also called
capital gains so if i buy a house for
let's say a hundred thousand i sell it
for two hundred thousand hundred
thousand is capital gains if i buy a
stock for ten dollars and sell it for
twenty the ten dollars of the capital
gains this is the second highest text
so the tax breaks that president trump
is working on today is primarily for
these guys here
so there are doctors lawyers
highly educated people and they have
stocks
most of these guys don't have stocks of
the working class they have a 401k
but they don't get the break
but these guys if you're active in
stocks and that kind of stuff of
flipping houses you get a break
but what the really rich work for
is
passive income
and passive income
[Applause]
for me
i have a business
whether i work or not money comes in
and you've seen me i'm not here am i no
never never
i've heard my right not to be here
real estate i get milli
every year my wife and i can we had more
real estate
also we have commodity income from oil
wells and things like this even the
stock price of oil doesn't go up and
down and all this we still get this
but this is another type of
income
this here i'll
get into is called phantom income
it's taxes i don't pay so it's a little
bit beyond most people's minds
but let's say my tax bill is a hundred
thousand dollars
by doing what the government wants here
the government may give me a fifty
thousand dollar tax break
that means fifty thousand in taxes i
don't have to pay
so the fifty thousand dollars didn't go
to the government they went back up here
so that's what financial education does
is it teaches you
about the financial statement which is
not taught in school again they teach
you fico scores which is really fido
scores
it was your total little dougie
okay
and then for you at your age now you
want to know this this is what they're
teaching you to work for now
ironically
when you save money and you have a 401k
this is the kind of income so savings in
401ks are taxed the highest types of
income
to me it's stupid but if you don't know
any better is the saving money in
what he called it 401ks is good
in canada it's called rrsp in australia
called the superannuation
but
this is what most people
have because they went to school they
got a job
and then this is what the rich really
have it's passive
and it's because
i'm an active investor i don't buy this
because this is passive investors
i am active and i'm professional in all
of these areas
so i work for passive income which means
i'm not here
the check comes in the checks come in
every year and you've seen kim and i
and your mother now she's working on
here
and so your mother's income keeps going
up your father's income keeps going up
and they don't have a job my dad did a
style of martial arts called
kyokushinkai
and um
and i suppose this little boy trying to
get close to dad i was like well if he's
doing it i'm going to join him
so my dad and i shared this incredible
passion of martial arts and cars right
um
so i kind of get started you know with
my father then he gets gunned down when
i'm 13 years old
and i went through like a year of just
nothing i just i couldn't show up at the
dojo i didn't have it in me
and i did all the things we're talking
about the excuses at the time south
africa had a a particularly high crime
problem and i was like you know what's
the point you know he has a first degree
black belt who gets attacked he get
takes nine bullets and he's dead anyway
why am i going to this thing called the
dojo right
again excuses valid it really is
but there's no progress
so a year nothing
and then and then i was like i actually
miss it so i went back
it was interesting when i went back it
wasn't the same
i wasn't doing the qatar
to impress the senseis anymore
i was doing the qatar because i wanted
every single movement
to be as close to flawless as i could
get it
it changed my entire perspective so
one of the things that happened you're
gonna love this i'm literally getting
chills thinking about it one of the
things that happened is time
just expanded
so right because we have a very finite
construct of time i'm going to be at the
dojo for an hour
but what happened was that hour be felt
like five hours and sometimes 30 minutes
felt like five
all of a sudden this fixed construct of
time
you know it started to change because my
relationship with what i was doing
changed
so it wasn't just a punch it wasn't just
the cutter i wasn't just i wasn't just
showing up for the emotion i was
embedded in every single part of the
process i was looking for growth for
progress right
i have to tell you that changed my
entire life
so anytime i find myself stuck now
i'm i recognize that the often the
reason i'm stuck is because i'm focusing
on the output and i'm not focusing on my
input right so output i've got to raise
a hundred million ran for my business
output i've got to get 300 growth for
you know in customers output i've got to
get 25 yeah that's all output
but what you got to focus on is input
what are the things i've got to do and
how do i do those things intentionally
deliberately and try to get better every
single time every meeting every impact
conversation with one of my staff
members every engagement with a client
or a potential client every single one
of those things how do i focus on that
moment because actually the output is a
sum total of how those things come about
so when you when you are at the dojo and
you are being graded and you are going
through the process of trying to attain
your black belt or your brown belt
that's what everybody sees as the output
but what actually went in was that
malleable construct of time where you're
trying to perfect every single
movement imagination is more powerful
than knowledge when dealing with your
own mind and the mind of others if i
said to any of you come and stand on
this ship who would come and stand on
this chair
i'll give you a hundred dollars to stand
on this chair sure if i said well now
the chair
is that is on top of that spire on the
highest building in thailand who's going
to climb up and stand in it for a
hundred dollars who would do that
some people would because they've got a
good imagination if i can stand on it
there i can send most people go no i
could fall you've got a little tiny
plank up here you can walk the plank
when it's on the floor
put the plank between two high-rise
buildings who's going to walk it
not many people because the
imagination that you could fall and kill
yourself is way more powerful than the
knowledge that i did this on the ground
it's wide enough
fear of flying
knowledge says it's actually the safest
place in the world the most dangerous
part of a flight is actually the drive
to the airport that's way more dangerous
than being in the plane do you think the
imagination cares we're going in a
flying coffin i'm hurtling through the
air and that guy looks like he's come
straight out of isis and he's in the bar
i think he's going to blow up the plane
and then you feel terrible the other
person's going i'm watching a movie i've
always wanted to watch the shape of
water this is so great
here's my time again to do nothing
so whatever you imagine will defeat
logic or defeat knowledge and when
dealing with children
people do logically why are you so bad
why can't you get it what's going on why
are you so naughty
and that doesn't work i never say to
kids why are you bad a girl what
happened to you the first thing to
realize is don't believe everything you
see in movies and read in books
you know there is no way both my wife
who worked for steve directly i worked
for steve could do that for 10 years
if there wasn't some amazing
stuff that came out of it it wasn't like
we were getting whipped every day it had
nothing to do with that
we were dedicated we were passionate he
was passionate
he wanted the best for the company for
the products for our customers
and when you're in that there's a
creative tension
and
he
emotionally would show that passion
sometimes sometimes it was oh my god
this is the best thing ever
you know you hear about the negatives
but you don't hear about all the
positives and all the great things he
did for you it did for the individual as
well as the company and all that stuff
so it was always a balance and those bad
days were not all very often but they
did happen because typically yeah
you might have made a mistake
don't do that again or we weren't
thinking about it right or somebody was
falling down on the job or whatever the
case may be
that's when it came out is when someone
didn't show respect for the mission they
were on when you didn't show respect for
the rest of your teammates and for the
thing we're trying to build that's when
there was a problem not when we were
falling when we fail when we tried
really hard and if we showed we tried
really hard then that was just an option
just like we the ipod phone was a
failure
no one got killed over that it was more
just a
you know okay we tried our best we move
on we tried our best we move on it's
when you were when you didn't
do what was right and you failed from a
because you didn't put your heart and
soul into it and you let the team down
that's when there was a problem
and that's what people need to realize
it was very balanced and he was very
much human passionate and he was very
helpful and all kinds of stuff but yes
he did have his bad days
but not usually for without reason in
life everything's about pivoting from
one thing to another you know stepping
stones right so i started looking at the
office buildings out of this state
because california you know it's like i
gotta expand my territory
so i started going on internet thank god
to internet now you can kind of get on
there and search everything you want
so i started looking at houston fourth
largest city in the nation a lot of
movement a lot of liquidity in real
estate a lot of you know product to
cherry pick from so i started
you know teaching myself researching
different zip codes
um
you know and and i realized the area
closer to airport is very active at
businesses with a lot of people flying
meaning so i stopped buying
smaller buildings you know three four
story buildings i bought three buildings
i think on my first visit i flew there
in 2004
remember the broker he showed me five
buildings i bought three of them on the
spot
we went to his office wrote the offer
and i flew back the same day i bought it
for i think nine point seven million
dollars i put three million dollars down
but the nice thing is you know i
had the experience already with
negotiating and adding and flipping so i
already knew
there's media on the bone on this
properties because i've already done it
you know for three four years
prior
and what was nice is i bought the
buildings and then california had kind
of plateaued 2004 to 2007. you didn't
get a huge price appreciation and people
were selling in that time and doing 1031
exchange where they want to take their
money yeah arizona and houston miami new
york so houston was one of the cities
where i got a lot of california money
moving into it and i was ahead of the
curve yeah so you started trend yeah so
by 2007 i had 130 million worth of real
estate all in houston mostly all of it
in houston and i sold in 2007.
most of them california buyers i'll ask
you a very simple question
why does your organization
exist
we don't need you clearly there's plenty
of competition clearly people have
plenty of choices
even the things that you may specialize
in there are others that do a reasonably
good job they might even be better than
you in some areas so why do you exist
providing education is table stakes
everybody here does that you can't rely
on that that's why the industry exists
not why your organization exists
that's like when i talk to healthcare
companies and say why does your
organization exist and they say to help
people be more healthy like no kidding
thank you
but i know that the culture of one
organization is different than the
culture of another organization
there are cultural norms that wrap
around the sense of purpose cause or
belief
great organizations understand their
just cause a cause so just
that people would be willing to
sacrifice to see the advancement of that
cause sacrifice comes in many forms it
might mean
working longer hours giving you my best
ideas turning down a better job that
offers me more money to stay here
because i believe in what you're doing
and i want to see that advanced
one of my favorite
examples of a just cause
is
the declaration of independence
our founding fathers
declared literally wrote down they
declared why
we needed our own country
all men are created equal
endowed with these unalienable rights
amongst which include life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness
they were never against britain
the whole point is not to be against
something but to stand for something
britain was simply standing in the way
of them advancing their cause and though
they won independence there are always
finite games within the infinite game
though they won independence
that didn't mean that they had now
provided all men are equal now the real
heavy lifting began
now let's be crystal clear when they
said all men are equal what they meant
was white protestant men let's be
crystal clear
but even early on during the
revolutionary war george washington
understood how limiting that was and he
realized that they had to have a broader
definition
so he included catholics
he banned any organizing against
catholics and his armies and he would
regularly attend mass to send the right
message some time later
we abolished slavery
and the 14th amendment
some time later we had women suffrage
sometime later we had
civil rights act sometime later we
implement gay rights and you can see
that we are striving
to provide this thing called all men are
equal people are equal and though we
will never actually get there we will
die trying and the obstacles may always
be different
and what a just cause is
it is a vision of the future that does
not yet exist and you will commit all of
your energies
to advance that vision of the world that
you have
and the people you want to attract both
those who work there those who teach
there and both those who come to learn
there
believe in your vision of the future
so much so
that they may turn down a better offer
from someone else
because they want to be
around people
who are committed to building this world
that does not yet exist and every single
single one of these organizations that
you
run and represent
can have different visions or
overlapping visions of the world but you
must be clear what your just cause is
what you stand for otherwise the only
thing i have to judge you on
is
superficial things
it's like dating right
it's like dating if if somebody tells me
what they stand for who they are they're
talking about their character and those
are the people we want to spend the rest
of our lives with
if we do not have any sense of who they
are what they stand for what their
purpose what their cause what their
beliefs are what their values are
the only thing we have to judge them on
is how much money they make and how good
looking they are many ideas that people
have and never actually acted on
when you first came up with the idea for
toms was this a a big serendipitous
moment for you what was it like
you know it's it's funny i get that
question a lot and you know people say
did you did your life change when you
thought of thompson when you had the
idea and as kind of romantic or noble as
it would be to say yes the truth is no
you know it was just an idea i mean i
was running my other business at the
time and i had this idea if i sell a
pair of shoes i can give a pair away and
and and it was just an idea but when it
became much more than idea and when my
life really did change was when i went
on that first shoe drop you know i took
my parents who had never left the united
states before i took my brother and
sister i took you know my intern
jonathan some of my friends and we went
down there 16 people who really didn't
know each other very well and we just
got on our hands knees and started
putting shoes on kids feet and we didn't
know what we were doing i mean you know
we had the shoes made and we knew where
the areas that kids needed them but it
was an unbelievable experience to see
that just six months before that it was
just an idea and this idea had had got
it got the attention of enough people to
buy ten thousand pairs of shoes so that
they we were allowed to go there and
give them away and i'll never forget
this one moment because it really was uh
life-changing for me we were leaving a
village and i was walking away and this
woman came up and she was crying and she
was running after me and she was
speaking in spanish and my spanish isn't
very good so i went and got my partner
alejo and he's argentine and said leho
ask her this woman what's wrong and she
had these three boys with her and they
all had brand new tom shoes on and he
said you know in spanish to her and when
she responded she started to smile
and he was smiling as he was listening
to her so before he even told me the
translation i knew she wasn't crying
because she was sad she was crying
because she was happy but what she told
alejo and what he told me just blew me
away she explained that her three sons
had been sharing a single pair of shoes
for the past year and what that meant
was her oldest son would go to school on
monday he would come home give his shoes
to his brother and have to wait until
thursday to go to school again wow i
mean can you imagine like i don't have
kids but i'm sure a lot of people in
this room do i mean can you imagine
if that was the case your family that
your children had to wait a couple days
to go to school because of a pair of
shoes
and i had no idea even when we started
tom said it was that much needed but
when that lady told alejo and he told me
and we got very emotional started crying
i mean it was like this really amazing
moment but that's when i knew that like
this is what i wanted to do with my life
going back to your book i think that one
thing that's really really interesting
about it is the way that you structure
it around like 80 of the book is the
excuses that you you literally tackle
them one by one i thought it was really
smart and then skill acquisition yeah so
why why that structure why excuses and
skills because that well the excuses are
just what i hear all day from women in
dms and emails standing in line at a
book signing it's all the reasons why
they can't do what they want to do and
um
makes my head explode because it's like
what like you're not ugh
it drives me crazy so i thought it's
well and good for us to talk about the
things that you need to do to achieve
this stuff but none of this matters if
you don't have this foundational
like presence of mind to get out of your
own way and to stop using that as a
crutch for why you can't
do what you want to do if i get flack
for anything in this space it's the idea
that i tell women that anybody can
accomplish anything and i really believe
that to the marrow of my bones because
there is no reason that i should have
the life that i have the business i've
built the being on state like i
shouldn't have any of this this is
working
every single day for the last 15 years
to achieve the thing that i want to
achieve you had said something recently
or maybe it was on your instagram where
someone said like how do i become a
speaker and you were like speak
everywhere everyone go everywhere
that
people like oh i would love to be a a
speaker but i can never talk like you
and i'm like
i spoke at old folks homes i spoke
because they can't run away by the way
if anyone needs this tip the people
laugh i'm like no was for real mops
groups which is mothers of preschoolers
they exist all over the country
i'd speak at the opening of an envelope
and i was horrible like my first
speeches it was this maybe something it
was like
and it's so embarrassing and you know
your hands are shaking and i had note
cards and i keep the videos on youtube
because i want people to see the
progression of what a decade looks like
i've done it so much you need me to do a
keynote right now i got you i can make
it up
but it didn't start that way it was so
many years and so much effort and the
problem is
people don't they're like well i can't
because or here's the reason why i'm
like yeah me too i had all those excuses
and it didn't mean that making the
decision to move forward
suddenly it got easier
if anything making the decision to move
forward is harder like because now um
john maxwell said this to me the other
day he's like which is the most named
drop you think but i was interviewing
him on the podcast we're not like you
know having a slumber party but he said
um
movement causes friction
always
and so it's you it just because you make
the decision to move forward doesn't
mean it you know now we're now we're
doing it no now you've got all kinds of
other problems so excuses were really
important for me to tackle just because
i i think
love my girls but women especially like
we need to call bs and you need to have
someone
get in your face and say like with all
the love in my heart this is not this is
not real this is something that you've
decided to cling to because it justifies
why you're still in the same place
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want seven more rich people habits to
try check the video right there next to
me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there you
absolutely must if you want to be
legendary in your marketplace you
absolutely have to do this schedule 60
minutes a day
for your learning it could be listening
to audiobooks